bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission à trois semaines du
scrutin nous avons décidé de nous mettre
à l'heure de la campagne pour les
européennes avec des politologues des
journalistes dans cette émission
direction l'allemagne le bon élève de
l'europe
le champion toutes catégories confondues
un budget une balance commerciale
excédentaire à tout chômage sous la
barre des 7% et une croissance estimée à
1,8 pour cent en 2014 mais il y a un
mais le modèle allemand c'est là où le
bas salaires blesse avec des
travailleurs pauvres qui attendent ces
millions de salariés précaires de ces
élections européennes c'est ce que nous
verrons tout à l'heure mais avant un
tout autre sujet à quoi va ressembler le
prochain parlement européen après le
scrutin du 25 mai en attendant les
résultats officiels on a en a on a des
sondages
les dernières estimations issues des
derniers sondages s'est tout de suite
principal groupe au parlement européen
la droite et le centre le ppe auquel
appartient l'ump
ils pointent en tête dans huit pays dont
l'allemagne et l'espagne
le groupe socialiste et démocrate auquel
appartient le ps voit lui c'est parti en
pole position dans neuf pays dont le
royaume uni et l'italie l'un de ses
chefs martin schulz et candidat à la
présidence de la commission
je tournais l'europe dans une autre
direction tourner le dos à ces
inégalités insupportables en erreur les
grands profiteurs et devant des
milliards des profits et ne paient pas
de taxes et quand ils font des milliards
de pertes ce sont les contribuables qui
payent pour urs et pas juste la gauche
unitaire dont est membre le front de
gauche arrive en première place
en grèce les écolos atteignent le sommet
du classement en belgique
l'extrême droite fait son meilleur score
en france aux pays bas en république
tchèque en pologne et au danemark
la plupart d'entre eux été membre
d'aucun groupe lors de la dernière
mandature des non-inscrits comme le
front national
si le peuple français nous placent en
tête le 25 mai prochain
le président de la république ne pourra
pas ignorer ne rejette la construction
européenne qui se sera exprimée en
france pour l'heure deux sondages ont
été réalisés dans des circonscriptions
françaises
puis une enquête ifop donne florian
philippot front national en tête dans
l'est juste devant l'ump nadine morano
dans le sud est
le rapport est inversé selon une autre
enquête l'ump renaud muselier devance le
frontiste jean-marie le pen
loin devant le socialiste vincent
peillon
alors trois invités m'ont rejoint
françois forest bonjour vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'ulb l'université libre de bruxelles à
vos côtés tom weingartner bonjour vous
êtes journaliste de la radio publique
allemande esi shirt rundfunk à vos côtés
route berkshire
bonjour du quotidien allemand
handelsblatt alors vous venez de voir ce
petit reportage ce sondage ce premier
sondage ça n'est qu'un sondage qu'est ce
qui vous inspire conçoit faudrait
d'abord que ça ne va pas être simple de
gérer cette diversité
après l'élection à chaud il ya quand
même des éléments intéressants qui
ressorte je crois on voit tout de même
l'influencent de la personnalisation du
scrutin est lié évidemment au nouveau
mécanisme liant la désignation du
président de la commission aux résultats
des élections européennes voir martin
schultz par exemple tenir un tel
discours accentué tionnement idéologique
notamment en allant vers une gauche un
peu plus musclé je crois qu'on voit là
clairement une dynamique transnationales
parce qu'il n'est pas sûr qu'un tel
discours en allemagne rencontre un
accueil un accueil tout à fait
enthousiaste ça mais mes collègues
spécialistes de la partie à dix c'est
une forme d'européanisation on voit que
les leaders ont conscience que
maintenant il s'adresse un peu plus
qu'avant encore à un public européen
les campagnes restent très national les
listes restent aussi très nationale mais
on voit quand même je crois cela ce
germe il ya la personnalisation qui veut
dire aussi organisation roots band
labarchède l'allemagne le ppe placé en
tête en allemagne oui bon c'est pas une
surprise à nouveau c'est pas du tout une
surprise puisque la chancelière marque
toujours un gouvernent déjà depuis 8 ans
9 ans maintenant elle est toujours très
populaire
c'est dû à soues fait que la queue leu
leu les chrétiens démocrates sont
toujours largement en tête les social
démocrates sont bien derrière bien on
t'arrête c'est pour le candidat souhaite
certainement une déception puisqu'il est
un allemand et il est candidat au poste
du président de la commission et
pourtant ça ne veut pas dire que les
social démocrates auront un succès
électoral en allemagne tom gardner lui
je pense c'est tout à fait ça les les
parcs mais il est parti aussi les partis
eurosceptiques font aussi en allemagne
sont sont très forts a légèrement et les
partis traditionnels aussi ils
reprennent certaines parties de leurs
discours partir mans par exemple la les
conservateurs en bavière sont aussi font
aussi une compagne est très heureux aux
critiques qui rejette certaines côté de
l'union européenne et donc on voit les
l'extrême droite qui fait qu'ils
feraient de bons scores donc en france
aux pays bas en république tchèque en
pologne et au danemark
ça vous inspire quoi on dit que ce sera
le premier parti de ces élections
vraiment ça me fait un petit peur
surtout pour la france puisque la france
est quand même la patrie de la
démocratie en europe si j'ose dire c'est
la france où s'est passée la révolution
française et c'est pour ça que j'ai un
peu peur pour la république française
puisque si le front n'arrive peut-être
en france qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est quand même c'est une image c'est
une catastrophe pour l'image de la
france en europe ce serait une
catastrophe et ça serait psy pour
l'europe entière
un très mauvais message et c'est pour ça
puisque le front national n'est pas un
parti majorité en france est un parti
minoritaire en france et pourquoi est ce
que ce parti peut arriver en tête
peut-être parce que les gens ne vont pas
voter et j'espère vraiment ça c'est
vraiment super fort
que les français vont voter pour
empêcher le front national arrivé en
tête aux élections européennes françois
forest c'est possible c'est parti
populiste que ces partis populistes soit
les gagnants de ces élections
européennes qui remporte un succès
certainement c'est indéniable entend
dire qu'il serait par exemple premier
est parti c'est déjà dire qu'il serait
un parti or je crois que ce qu'on voit
aussi c'est l'extrême diversité de ses
formes
quand on met d'abord la nation en avant
il est compliqué parler d'europe
et pourtant je trouve qu'il parle
d'europe alors peut-être suis-je d'un
optimisme indécrottable mais on voit
aussi que même l'extrême droite doit
constituer des alliances doit intégrer
l'europe comme horizon même pour la
critique est donc d'abord c'est pas un
phénomène radicalement nouveau en nature
en de grès certes bon c'est parti là
étaient présents auparavant
donc je crois qu'il ya pas de rupture
après il faudra voir une fois dans le
jeu européen ce qu'ils vont faire
moi je ne suis pas aussi catastrophiste
parce que s'ils veulent exister de toute
façon il faudra composer avec les règles
du jeu du jeu européen
mais c'est un signal à entendre
évidemment autre question est
d'actualité celle là la france at elle
une chance de devenir un des bons élèves
de l'europe la commission de bruxelles a
donc commencé à examiner le projet de
budget de paris pour les mois les années
qui viennent
verdict des experts il ne croit pas aux
engagements du gouvernement de revenir à
3% du déficit l'an prochain mais ils
reconnaissent qu'il y à alléger mieux
regarder
et voici bruxelles qui douche les
espoirs de la france trois fois par an
la commission européenne présente ses
prévisions économiques pour les 28 pays
de l'union une nouvelle fois bruxelles
est moins optimiste que la france pour
cette année elle prévoit une croissance
française de 1 % comme le gouvernement
mais en 2015 ce sera 1,5 pour cent
seulement soit moins que les prévisions
de l'équipe de manuel valls
et c'est surtout sur le déficit que la
commission ne fait pas confiance à la
france
il sera selon elle de 3 9% cette année
et de 3 4% en 2015
elle ne croit donc pas à la promesse
d'atteindre l'an prochain les
sacro-saints 3% du pacte de
responsabilité
pour son premier déplacement à bruxelles
le nouveau ministre des finances l'a sur
bruxelles ne sait pas tout la commission
a fait un travail de prévision à partir
d'un certain nombre d'éléments mais bien
entendu pas de la totalité des éléments
qu'elle l'ordre à apprendre et donc une
journée de travail comme celle ci nous
met très utile elle me permet de décrire
précisément tous les aspects du pacte de
responsabilité
point positif néanmoins la commission
européenne prévoit pour l'an prochain
une très légère baisse du chômage
voilà et pour être complet sur
l'ensemble de la zone euro la commission
européenne anticipe désormais une
croissance de 1,7 pour cent pour la zone
euro en 2015 contre 1,8 pour cent
précédemment donc une anticipation à la
baisse première question toute simple
est ce que est ce que c'est possible que
la france soit sanctionné oui c'est
possible après on atteint un niveau
vraiment politique là la commission
c'est son travail elle exerce le mandat
qu'on lui a donnée est ce qu'il fallait
lui donner c'est super qu'il est
fonctionnel
voilà mais après je crois qu'il ya la
dimension proprement politique il ya ce
qu'il faudrait faire d'après les textes
et puis il ya ce qui ne faudrait pas
faire en termes politiques donc comme
souvent je pense que ça va se traduire
par un compromis ou où les intérêts de
chacun sont sont respectées mais il faut
quand même aussi tenir compte qu'on a
pris des engagements et quand on exige
de la grèce qu'elle respecte ses
engagements la france est d'accord quand
ses partenaires exige de la france
qu'elle respecte les siens on renâcle
bon c'est humain mais il faut aussi
quand même voir dans le long terme
quel regard au delà en allemagne sur ses
engagements pris par la france
si j'ose dire tu as un petit peu de
patience la vraie vie ce qu on a quand
même des règles budgétaires en europe et
on a déjà deux fois donner plus de temps
à la france pour arriver aux 3% et
maintenant une troisième fois est ce
qu'on doit donner une troisième fois à
nouveau dès les gens s'assurent le
meilleur geste 106 pas certaine mais je
pense que peut-être l'allemagne ça va
dépendre un petit peu de la volonté
politique en france y poursuivre les
réformes que le président de la
république a annoncé paris il ya quand
même des réformes que je trouve ce sont
des bonnes réformes
par exemple la réforme territoriale
c'est une bonne réforme et on va bien
mary fier à bruxelles si la france
mince en ce qui concerne la forme et
dans ce cas là si elle le fait je pense
qu'un troisième une troisième reconduite
soit possible tom van gartner
d'allemagne la patiente vis-à-vis des
engagements france elle respectée moi je
crois à des fins non les allemands
je crois avons insisté que la france va
tenir ses engagements je crois aussi ce
serait un très mauvais signe pour le
pacte de stabilité et tous tous ces
pactes qu'on a fait là dans les
dernières années pour stabiliser
l'économie
ce serait un très mauvais signe si les
français échapperait là à leurs
engagements et s'ils tiennent pas aussi
à des sanctions parce que là le pacte de
stabilité seraient morts donc on a parlé
de ses prévisions de croissance donc à
la baisse une politique donc aussi
d'austérité assumer par bruxelles est-ce
que c'est pas ça qui va faire des dégâts
le 25 mai prochain aux élections
jetair il à dire la politique de rigueur
en grèce là la gauche unitaire dans les
sondages c'est vrai que d'un côté la
politique c'est vrai que la politique de
rigueur est pas populaire c'est vrai que
si on si on coupe dans les dépenses
publiques ce n'est pas populaire ça
c'est évidemment comme ça mais d'un
autre côté si la dette monte monte monte
on a vu pendant la crise de l'euro ce
que ça donne on a vu qu'il ya des pays
membres de la zone euro qui n'arrivent
plus à se financer
autonome eux-mêmes qui ont besoin du
soutien des autres donc ça c'est pas
vraiment une voix et c'est pas une bonne
chose et c'est pour ça mon avis que
chaque pays
aussi la france doit réfléchir comment
gérer sa dette publique on voit bien que
cette politique ne fonctionne pas on
voit la france à un déficit bien
supérieur à ce qui est permis et la
croissance est tout même pas là alors ça
fonctionne pas
justement parlons de l'allemagne il
s'agit du bon élève de l'europe le
champion toutes catégories confondues
donc un budget et une balance
commerciale excédentaire à tous le
chômage sous la barre des 7% une
croissance estimée à vue lui pour cent
en 2014
mais le modèle avancé aussi les mini
jobs et les bas salaires quel est le
prix de cette compétitivité exemplaires
en zone euro 14 6 millions de salariés
précaires pauvres de ces élections
européennes ne regardez le reportage de
germain andrieu
voici le bon élève européen le modèle
allemand ici le salaire minimum a été
votée mais n'est pas encore appliquée
l'allemagne c'est huit millions de
salariés gagnant moins de huit euros
brut de l'heure
l'autre visage du miracle allemand ce
sont les mini jobs 15 à 20 heures de
travail hebdomadaire pour 400 euros par
mois
tm moniteur
il ya beaucoup de personnes aussi avec
un mini jobs mais il vaudrait mieux
qu'ils trouvent un vrai boulot avec un
vrai salaire les employeurs préfèrent
surtout donner des mini jobs
car pour eux c'est moins de contraintes
si l'allemagne est en bonne santé
économique c'est aussi grâce à sa
réforme du marché du travail en 2003
avec gerhard schröder
dans ce centre sportif ce patron emploi
une partie de ses salariés grâce aux
contrats mini jobs une souplesse
indispensable pour son activité mon
point de vue c'est que tout cela a
apporté plus de possibilités et de
flexibilité aux entrepreneurs mais cela
a aussi permis à des personnes au
chômage ou en situation précaire de
retrouver un emploi
ces mini jobs elisabeth les connaît par
coeur informatique centre d'appel ou
restauration pour elle c'est toujours le
même contrat et elle vient de perdre son
dernier emploi voilà c'est le restaurant
dans lequel j'ai travaillé avant je
travaillais ici comme serveuse
j'ai aussi aidé un peu en cuisine jeux
gagnés 7 euros de l'heure sans compter
les pourboires
à l'arrivée ça faisait un salaire
correct mais pas fantastique
déçu mais pas inquiète retrouver un
travail ici n'est pas vraiment difficile
il suffit de franchir la porte d'un job
center
ici vous avez la description du poste et
les compétences requises et voilà votre
salaire 450 euros par mois et vous
pouvez me dire combien je vais gagner
pas rare non ce n'est pas indiqué les
inconvénients ce sont surtout les
conditions de licenciement
l'assurance maladie les vacances en fait
on n'a aucun droit et on doit souvent
changé de job
en ce qui me concerne j'ai déjà été
licenciés où j'ai dû arrêter parce que
les horaires ne m'allait plus bref il
faut toujours rester flexible au delà de
cette flexibilité des mini jobs le
secret de la compétitivité allemande
ce sont aussi les millions d'emplois non
qualifiés et payé bien en dessous du
salaire minimum envisagée à 8 euros 50
en france il est à 9 euros 50 de l'heure
alors à berlin
on espère une avancée sociale grâce à
l'europe ce soir elisabeth assiste à une
réunion du spd sur ce que l'europe peut
lui apporter
pour commencer je vous propose un petit
rappel sur le fonctionnement de l'europe
au programme beaucoup de pédagogie mme
elisabeth n'est pas vraiment convaincu
moi je pense que ces grands partis ne
sont pas vraiment la solution car il
parle surtout entre eux alors que les
petits partis sont plus proches des gens
j'espère vraiment qu'un salaire minimum
va être mise en place et qu'avec
l'europe tout cela fonctionne un jour
après la rigueur de gerhard schröder les
travailleurs port allemand espère de
l'europe plus d'harmonisation sociale
il faudra encore patienter le salaire
minimum ne sera pas mise en place avant
le 1er janvier 2017
voilà un reportage signé germain andrieu
je vais m'adresser tout de suite à mes
invités journalistes allemands alors ces
mini jobs ou peut se faire licencier
facilement où on est payé à 450 euros le
mois cette flexibilité c'est ça le prix
à payer pour être le bon élève de
l'europe
je pense une partie oui c'est ça et avec
le avec les salaires minimums il faut
voir que nature mans une partie des des
postes qui existent aujourd'hui vont
disparaître il ya pas de questions
certaines parties des entreprises vont
être capables de passer des coûts
supplémentaires à leurs clients mais
ceux qui ne peuvent pas faire ça vont
supprimer ces postes
alors c'est à dire ce sera pas bon pour
l'emploi c'est un fait une concession
pour la politique sociale c'est bien et
moi je ne suis pas contre le salaire
minimum mais je crois pour l'emploi ça
va pas y est on va payer un prix c'est
vrai que peut-être le monsieur schneider
alors l'ancien chancelier un peu exagéré
avec ses réformes de la politique
sociale avec son agenda 2010 comment ça
s'appelle chez nous et c'est vrai qu'il
a exagéré parce que quand même le
travail précaire a énormément augmenté
c'était maintenant le gouvernement à
corriger un petit peu le cap et on va
introduire un smic en 2010 est de ce kit
ce qui était évoqué dans mon petit fils
pourtant c'est une bonne chose
l'autre côté il ya aussi beaucoup de
critiques en ce qui concerne le smic on
a man est ce que mon collègue vient
d'évoquer par exemple dans l'allemagne
de l'est
les salaires générale sont beaucoup plus
bas qu'on le doit qu'à l'ouest
l'allemagne est peut-être beaucoup par
exemple les coiffeuses c'est une scène
c'est un exemple vont peut-être
maintenant perdre leur emploi parce que
à ce niveau de salaire donc cette
organisation sociale parce que c'est une
harmonisation sociale vis-à-vis des
voisins européens aussi elles
établissent ans le smic ou penser que ça
va être négatif pour pour l'allemagne à
ce mix négatif ou nadal
c'est un côté c'est positif si je suis
d'accord avec cette analyse que ça peut
coûter des emplois en allemagne
c'est aussi la vérité je pourrai ainsi
qu'une harmonisation par rapport à l'est
par exemple peut-être par rapport à la
france où le smic et à 9,50 mais par
rapport à la pologne nature bon ça
augmente plutôt la différence et si on
compare la situation en france et en
allemagne
c'est vrai quand on a des gens qui
travaillent qui sont pauvres mais en
fait on a le choix entre les projets
forest quel regard vous portez sur le
modèle allemand je n'ai pas l'expertisé
de la société allemande de mes collègues
mais ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que c'est l'allemagne
décrite comme le chantre de la rigueur
qui ramène sur l'agenda européen le
débat sur le salaire minimum
harmonisation sociale je crois qu'il
faut attendre un peu avant d'en parler
mais en tout cas voilà ça y est on est
dans le dur dans l'intégration
européenne jusqu'à présent on a mis en
relation des marchés est maintenant
s'ouvre le débat sur finalement le
modèle social un qui doit contrebalancer
l'intégration par le marché alors c'est
un débat très difficile on voit bien
quand on parle de salaire minimal on ne
dit pas du tout la même chose selon les
pays mais enfin on pose cette question
des valeurs et de la solidarité aux
fondements de l'ordre politique on ne
fait qu'effleurer le débat dans les
élections européennes actuelles mais je
trouve que c'est aussi une avancée et
c'est un débat qui va prendre des années
et c'est un débat qui va déchirer
l'autre est ce que c'est parce que les
gens les peuples qu'on parle un peu de
ceci pas nécessairement que d'économie
mais qu'on parle aussi de 2 de ceux de
leurs conditions de vie de social c'est
certainement inévitable à la longue
nature man city on a une union monétaire
une union économique le problème d'avoir
des des standards sociaux se pose
naturellement mais il faut se font voir
que les les fondements pour un système
social sont très très différents à des
niveaux très différents
c'est à dire avant de d'harmoniser par
exemple ce qui est la discussion
l'assurance chômage contre la bulgarie
et le long de ça il ya des nombres par
exemple si on parle de la
d'harmonisation rue par exemple le smic
le smic par leur en france 7,9 euros 50
on a mal ça sera peut-être 2008 58,5 en
toi ô en grèce ou au portugal
c'est beaucoup moi c'est peut-être six
mois je sais qu'on n'est pas le chiffre
est que j'acceptais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire l'harmonisation ça veut dire
un smic inférieur qu'aujourd'hui en
france sas elle les suit larry d'accord
c'est le modèle français qui devrait
être abaissé ce qui me colle aux 1
oui mais la réalisation ça veut dire
qu'on se retrouve au milieu c'est
toujours ça mais si je peux me permettre
dans le reportage trouve qu'il était
mentionné des attentes placées en
l'europe pour en quelque sorte renforcer
la dimension sociale dans la politique
nationale
je crois que c'est là le vrai défi pour
l'union européenne concernant les droits
fondamentaux par exemple l'union
européenne et considéré dans beaucoup de
pays comme un rempart contre d'éventuels
abus des pouvoirs nationaux
si l'europe arrive à jouer ce rôle-là en
matière sociale ça sera un renversement
complet de l'image actuelle de l'union
européenne c'est là le défi évidemment
ça sera sûrement pas un salaire minimal
unique le même dans tous les pays
européens mais là il ya un défi
constitutif pour l'union européenne
je crois pas qu'elle puisse les
relations c2c de la compétence exclusive
des états c'est de la politique sociale
et dans un cadre de coordination qui
fait que l'europe pèse quand même
d'accord allez on termine avec le happy
voting ou quand l'europe veut mobiliser
ses troupes pour les élections
européennes
happy voting c'est on se pose la
question est-ce que c'est par remède à
l'abstention des jeunes regarder ça
swingue
comment
non
voilà rapide voting l'abstention surtout
l'abstention des jeunes c'est ce qu'on
craint pour le vannes ça mais cette
abstention c'est possible une forte
abstention
ah oui c'est possible c'est même
probable moi je suis toujours content de
voir des jeunes qui s'amusent mais faut
pas prendre les jeunes pour des
imbéciles non plus de riz voilà le voit
de ses sérieux et je crois que les
jeunes se mobilisent aussi tout à fait
pour des raisons sérieuses mais c'est
très bien que ça existe ce genre de mai
on se sent pas un engouement alors cette
campagne est là
dans cette campagne
électorale européenne comment vous la
voyez en france elle intervient juste
après des municipales alors la campagne
électorale on doit le dire n'est pas
hyper passionnante se dire mais pourquoi
un taux d'abstention aussi élevé à mon
avis la raison c'est on ne peut pas
réparer avec une campagne électorale qui
dure un mois les les dégâts qu'on a fait
pendant les amis avant les vacances ça
veut dire que les politiques surtout les
politiques nationaux en allemagne en
france pour tous pratiquement ne voulait
pas alors par très mauvais de l'union
européenne on accuse tout le temps
bruxelles les institutions européennes
quand quelque chose ne va pas et on
n'arrive pas il a quand même dans les
médias dans vos médias respectifs vous
arrivez à vendre l'europe
on essaie mais de toute façon en a
durement et nous on fait pas la
politique c'est à dire si les
politiciens nationaux au fond l'union
européen le bouc émissaire pour pour
tous les maux qu'ils en couleurs nous on
peut bien réparer ça moi je crois il ya
un élément qui qui qui me rend un peu
plus optimistes entre guillemets je veux
dire pour le pour le vote
c'est la crise en ukraine moi je
pourrais m'imaginer que notamment dans
les pays de l'est
ça va augmenter le taux de participation
éventuellement parce que nature mans
cpge âge sont ils se sont plus concernés
et ce sont ce refuge un peu vers
l'europe avec les menace qu'ils ont à
leur frontière est merci en tout cas mes
trois invités d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fa d'europe hebdo
merci de l'avoir suivi bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
why